[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
remember they needed to face in Congress
about the debt ceiling a couple of years
ago that led to a government shutdown
it's coming back up next month Congress
eventually decided to suspend the limit
in October of 2015 but the u.s. is
suspension on borrowing limits expires
tomorrow March 16th and we're going to
probably face another one of these
battles between Democrats and
Republicans about what to do with the
budget and recent stalemates over the
debt ceiling led to two government
shutdowns during the Clinton
administration a 2011 hit to the
american credit rating after republicans
threatened to make the treasury default
on loans and it almost happened again at
the end of 2012 and the last two times
that the debt limit expired ended with
relatively peaceful suspensions of the
limit but here we go again
with yet another deadline and again as a
reminder the debt ceiling is an
arbitrary limit on the total amount of
debt that the American government can
have on paper if Congress doesn't raise
the debt ceiling they will have to make
cuts on things like people's retirement
funds for instance or default on the
debt Republican leaders in Congress are
insisting that they're not going to push
things to the last minute and use this
as a bargaining chip like they've done
in the past Trump so far hasn't said
what his stance is on this issue as
president I think he's still tied up
trying to figure out if a strong or weak
dollar is good he called Mike Flynn at
3:00 a.m. and didn't get a solid answer
from him so he's probably still working
on that little project and different
Trump budget advisers have expressed
varied opinions about how to deal with
this you've got Treasury secretary and
former Goldman Sachs hedge fund manager
Stephen minuchin who has said that
making good on our debt is a quote
critical commitment then you've got the
head of the Office of Management and
Budget Mick Mulvaney who has said that
raising the debt ceiling might not be
the most important thing in the world we
know that Trump is no stranger to not
making good on debts but that's not
going to necessarily tell us what's
going to happen with the issue of the
debt ceiling so a few things number one
the debt ceiling doesn't account for
inflation or the size of the economy
okay so in
relation alone would mean that the debt
ceiling has to go up in raw dollars
merely to account for the real dollar
value of the debt as inflation happens
and the other issue as I mentioned is
the total size of the economy the debt
limit has to go up to represent the same
portion of the economy and a simple way
to think about this is imagine a billion
dollar debt if you have a five billion
dollar economy a billion dollar debt
means something very different than if
you have a fifty billion dollar economy
or a five hundred billion dollar economy
but those are just logistics right
there's a bigger reason that this is a
political game and not really the
important issue that many make it out to
be the US isn't really trying to pay off
the debt nor is it meant to pay off the
debt and having that in your mind as a
sort of baseline for analysis it's just
a distraction right wingers who believe
that the way to a better economy is to
pay off the whole debt are more likely
to be against raising the debt ceiling
but what really matters isn't that it's
the ability of the United States to
service the debt in other words stay on
top of payments do on the debt and to
continue funding government programs
that millions and millions of Americans
depend on if you can't service the debt
that's a different story then you start
having problems getting other entities
to loan you money which makes it so that
you have to print more money which
devalues the money and then you
basically have your own Federal Reserve
buying your debt and that's a cycle that
is not sustainable but as long as you
can service the debt Pat this singular
focus on the debt ceiling number is a
hilarious political distraction I mean
you could say that the interest on the
national debt could be somewhat of a
concern because as a total expenditure
that's going to increase over time sure
but all together I don't think the
Republicans are going to make a big fuss
about this I mean Congress has raised
the debt ceiling I think 74 times since
1962 and they only make a fuss about it
when a Democrat is in a mobile office
it's made a fuss out of in order to be
politically advantageous that's sort of
the reality and even though you're right
that over time the cost of servicing the
debt is going to go up
is it going to go up in relation to the
size of the economy and inflation
adjusted once again we always have to
consider that so you're absolutely right
but we still have to make those
adjustments
we'll see what ultimately happens on
this issue today's episode of the David
Pakman show is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which one do you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription in
- I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine costs at including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS